we just want to bring you some words
from the Prime Minister Rishi sunak has
been speaking at a school in South
London this week no doubt informing them
all about his plans to make them Carry
On Learning maths until the age of 18
but he's been taking some questions
including one on the emergency
anti-strike legislation that the
government announced yesterday afternoon
let's have a listen to what he said
well first of all it's great to be here
at Harris Battersea this morning talking
to some of the amazing teachers and
fantastic students all the opportunities
that I've had in my life began with the
fact that I was fortunate to receive an
amazing education it's one of the most
important reasons I got into politics
was to ensure that every one of our
children has a brilliant education
that's why we invested billions pound
more in schools in the Autumn statement
but we've got to keep going because
every child deserves a fantastic
education it's one of the most powerful
things we can do for them in our country
and that's what the government's
priority is you know with regard to
strikes you know yesterday the
government wrote to all union leaders
inviting them in for talks on Monday you
know incredibly value the important work
that our public sector workers do
especially our nurses and we want to
have an honest grown-up conversation
about what's affordable what's
responsible for the country those
invitations have gone out and I'm
hopeful that those meetings can happen
on Monday so we can have a productive of
conversation and find a way through this
and just on the legislation that you
brought in could people be sacked for
not going to work in the Health Service
so you know I I fully believe in the
Union's role in our society and the
freedom for them to strike but I also
believe that that should be balanced
with the right of ordinary working
people to go about their lives free from
significant disruption and that's why
we're going to bring forward new laws in
common with countries like France Italy
Spain and others that ensure that we
have minimum levels of safety in
critical areas like fire like ambulance
so that even when strikes are going on
you know that your health will be
protected I think that's entirely
reasonable and that's what our new laws
will do when it comes to the current
industrial action being taken by nurses
they've indicated that they might be
willing to settle for 10 could you go a
bit further with your payoff could you
meet them halfway and we've always been
clear that we want to have a grown-up
honest conversation a two-way
conversation with union leaders and
that's why the government has written
all departments have written to all
their unions inviting them in for talks
on Monday so that we can have those
conversations talking about what's
affordable what's reasonable what's
responsible for our country I think
everyone agrees that the most pressing
economic priority we have is reducing
the cost of living and getting a grip of
inflation is the best way we can do that
to ease the cost of living not only for
nurses but for everyone and that's why
earlier this week I made five promises
about what I wanted to do and that was
to halve inflation grow the economy
reduce debt cut waiting lists and stop
the boats will those talks that you're
talking about inviting unions in for
include talks about this year's pay so
what we do is what we've said is we want
to have a grown-up honest conversation
with all union leaders about what is
responsible what is reasonable and what
is Affordable for our country when it
comes to pay we think that those
conversations should happen that's why
we've invited everyone in to have those
talks on Monday and I'm hopeful that
those talks will be constructive and we
can find a way through this beyond the
industrial and rest in the wider NHS
there is a crisis people are we don't
know how many but people are almost
certainly unnecessarily dying does that
trouble you the NHS is obviously under
enormous pressure as we recover from
covid and I have enormous admiration for
all the people working incredibly hard
in the NHS right now to help get us
through that now we are supporting them
with billions of pounds of extra funding
but in particular this winter what we
want to do is make sure that we move
people out of hospitals into social care
into communities that's one of the most
powerful ways we can ease some of the
pressures on a e departments and
ambulances that are waiting too long if
we can move people into social care
that's why we've put money into doing
that we need to make sure that money
reaches the front line and makes a
difference and there's various other
initiatives that we're rolling out that
will also help ease some of the burdens
but people should rest assured you know
one of my promises that I made this week
was to tackle NHS weights and I'm fully
committed to doing that we're putting
the extra money in and we need to make
sure that the initiatives that we've put
in place actually make a difference but
this is what I'm focused on I've set out
five promises for the country three this
week to halve inflation reduce debt cut
waiting lists stop the boats grow the
economy that's what I'm prioritizing
you spoke also in your speech earlier
this week about the importance of family
and you spoke about how important your
family is to you how do you feel then
when you see the royal family being so
publicly torn apart
I think as you would expect it's not
appropriate for me to comment on matters
to do with the Royal Family
more broadly Prince Harry has talked
about the number of Taliban fighters he
believed he killed in Afghanistan just
on the point about military personnel
talking about the number of people they
believe they have killed is that wise
does that create a security risk for
anyone who's been in the forces you know
again I wouldn't comment on matters to
do with the royal family I would just
say I'm enormously grateful to our Armed
Forces for the incredible job they do in
keeping us all safe we're all very
fortunate for their service